- I wanna show you two video clips.
One of them is real and
one of them is fake.
Can you tell which one's real?
Okay. This one was kind of easy.
Obviously this is the fake one.
Like you can see the color on
the face isn't quite right,
and the hair is obviously like a wig.
But this video was like
from a few years ago.
Let's look at a more recent example.
Look at these two clips.
One of them is real,
and one of them is fake.
Can you tell which one it is?
Okay, what about these?
Or these?
Which one of these is fake,
and which one of these is real?
Maybe you're some wizard and
you could tell, but I couldn't.
And my guess is that most people can't.
That's because things have changed.
- I've never seen it quite like this.
- [Woman] This technology
is spreading rapidly.
- It's really extreme.
- Mind blowing.
- Deepfakes.
- [Man] Deep Tom Cruise was a
tipping point for deepfakes.
- It's all real.
- In the last few years,
we've crossed a threshold,
into a world where moving
images are manipulated
in ways that make them
indistinguishable from reality.
This is our new world.
It is the world of high quality deepfakes.
- The catastrophic
potential to public trust,
and to markets, that could
come from deepfake attacks.
- This is happening quicker than any of us
could have imagined.
So I wanna get you up to speed
on what's happening with deepfakes,
how they're revolutionizing entertainment.
- It's all my fault.
(speaks foreign language)
- [Johnny] And creating
new challenges and fears
for the people who make our laws,
and the people who enforce those laws.
- They can make it look like
anyone is saying anything
at any point in time.
- Ultimately, I wanna show
you how much of a threat
deepfakes actually pose,
and answer the biggest question of all.
What is even real?
Seeing is not believing anymore.
Okay, it's actually me.
This is the real Johnny.
I promise this is not a deepfake.
I promise!
I'm not like gonna do like
some little bait and switch.
I need to tell you about the
sponsor of today's video,
which is a thing I'm really excited about.
I'm genuinely excited!
Not just because they're
supporting the channel,
but because I'm actually excited!
For years now, I have been in
a war with marketing people.
Secretive, shadowy marketing people
who collect all of my
data, put it on lists,
lots of lists, and then
sell it to corporations
who then flood my inbox and my
phone and my life, with spam.
Lots of spam.
This ends up creating a
lot of noise in my life,
a lot of noise that I don't want.
And it has been impossible for me to
actually get myself off these lists,
until Incogni came around.
What many of us don't know is that
we actually have legal protections against
our data being bought and sold,
and these predatory marketing practices
coming to bear on us all of the time.
But it is a very complicated
and time intensive process
to actually implement those rights.
With Incogni, you can get
your name off of these lists.
The creepiest part about
this whole industry
is that there are people
search websites now,
where random people can just look you up
and learn a bunch of stuff about you.
Incogni targets those as well.
It's so satisfying, because
they show you a dashboard
of all of like, the marketing
lists that they're working on,
to take your name off of.
So you get to see your
name being taken off of
all of these lists that you
didn't even know you were on.
So, I'm signed up for the yearly plan,
which means Incogni is
constantly monitoring
month after month, to
keep me off these lists.
And I'm already seeing the results.
I'm very very happy that Incogni exists,
which is why I'm so giddy right now.
There's a link in my description.
It's incogni.com/johnnyharris.
Clicking that link helps
support the channel.
It also gets you in on
this amazing service.
You can sign up and
have 30 days risk free,
where you can get all your money back
if you feel like it's not useful to you.
30 days.
Use the link, go sign up.
Thank you Incogni, for
sponsoring today's video.
Let's dive back into the wild,
weird world of deepfakes.
Okay, let's just be clear.
We've been faking the moving
image for at least 100 years.
- [Man] America goes to war!
- Thomas Edison wanted to
spice up his news reporting
from the front lines of
the Spanish American War
back in like, the end of the 1800s.
So to do this, he shot
some fake battle scenes
in New Jersey,
and then cut them together
with shots from Cuba,
making this look like it
was happening in Cuba,
and it wasn't.
And for the next 100 years,
motion picture manipulation
remained as crude and simplistic
as Edison's sneaky editing.
But then suddenly, in 2014,
with the invention of a new type of AI,
everything started to change.
- [Man] Incredibly realistic
so-called deepfakes.
- How similar it is.
Is there a way to know when this is fake,
and to tell when it's fake?
- We now have the ability
to make people look like other people.
Like, I could be Johnny,
or I could be Nick, the studio manager.
Look, I'm Nick the
studio manager right now.
I could also be Tom, the music composer.
And what's crazy is even
if you go back and watch
what I just showed you frame by frame,
you likely won't be able to tell.
Let me explain how on earth we did this.
We can do all of this because of this
clever computing process.
It's called Generative
Adversarial Networks, or GANS.
This is where two AIs work in tandem,
to get the best fake image possible.
So you have these two AIs.
One of them is a forger, and
the other is a detective.
The forger creates an image
based on what you ask it to make,
and then it shows that image
to the other AI, the detective.
The detective goes over the image,
and points out all of
the reasons it's fake.
It knows what to look for,
because it's been trained on hundreds,
sometimes thousands of images
of exactly what the finished products
are supposed to look like.
The forger is like, okay, cool.
Let me try again.
And it goes away and
it makes another image,
fixing the pixels that the
detective AI pointed out.
Then it shows it to the detective.
The detective AI once again points out
all of the weaknesses in the fake image,
and the forger goes back
and makes a new one.
And over and over and over again.
And so the longer you give
one of these AI models to train on,
it basically goes through this creation
and improvement cycle, over and over,
until you get the best deepfake possible.
There are many ways to train a deepfake,
but this is the most common,
and it's actually how we got the deepfake
that we're running on this clip right now.
My face is slowly morphing
into something else,
and it's basically pixel perfect.
We had to run a training model
on this face for two weeks.
But it got really good. Look.
It's like, amazing.
I'm not me. I mean I am me.
But I'm not me to you.
And that's kind of nuts.
- We're about to enter a brave new world.
- It scares me, it really does.
It scares me.
- An important point here is that,
we used to have to train these models
on huge amounts of data.
You need a lot of footage
from someone's face
to train these models.
Which is why it's mostly
worked on like, actors,
who have a lot of high
quality face data available.
It's how you get deepfakes like this.
- Do you like what you're seeing?
Just wait till what's coming next.
- [Johnny] Or how you get Jim Carrey
imposed onto Jack Nicholson's
face in The Shining.
- I'm not gonna hurt you.
- [Johnny] Or Willem Dafoe
in Silence of the Lambs
instead of Anthony Hopkins.
- You look like a rube.
- These last two clips were done
by a super talented deepfake artist
named Control Shift Face.
And he's actually the one
who's doing the deep
fakes for this video too.
He's the artist behind
that video that went
super viral a few years ago,
of Bill Hader doing an Arnold
Schwarzenegger impression,
and turning into Arnold Schwarzenegger.
- Get out of there!
There's a bomb in there!
Get out!
- And he's now working at a
deepfake production company
called Deep Voodoo,
where he worked on that
Kendrick Lamar video.
Yes, that Kendrick Lamar video.
- For me personally,
it's exciting because I can like do this
goofy, funny movie remixes
that I can put on YouTube.
I really enjoy that.
- And yes, when I was talking
to him in our interview,
he was using a live deep fake mask
and changing between different characters,
and it kind of blew my mind.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
He just changed, you just
changed to Mark Zuckerberg.
- I've got lots of faces
up my sleeves here.
- Oh my god!
Wow, I did not, I was not ready for that.
Deepfaking has already started to shape
the entertainment industry.
(upbeat music)
Filmmakers are using deepfake technology
to translate films into other languages.
- And it's all my fault!
(speaks foreign language)
- They can de-age celebrities.
- I (indistinct) went anywhere.
- Yeah, and we're back!
- There's a six part TV show in the UK
about a bunch of rowdy
neighbors, and guess what?
All of these characters are
all deepfaked celebrities.
- I did move some of Kim's things.
I'm sorry about that.
- Two years ago, if someone
told me something like this
would exist, I don't
think I would believe him.
And what will be next in like,
another two, three, five years?
- It's getting to the
point where deepfakes
are nearly impossible to
decipher as computer generated,
which is super exciting,
but also kind of scary.
- [Man] The FBI tells NBC news
they're following the rapidly
developing technology closely.
- I believe that this is
the next wave of attacks against America.
- It's a real concern.
It's a real concern.
(dark electronic music)
- And this is where we talk
about the doom and gloom part.
And for that, yes, I have a lot of paper.
(dramatic music)
Lawmakers and law enforcement
are getting worried about this technology.
Here's a letter from Congress,
to the director of National Intelligence,
raising the alarm that,
"Hyper-realistic digital forgeries,
popularly referred to as deepfakes,
use sophisticated machine
learning techniques
to produce convincing depictions
of individuals doing or saying
things that they never did."
I kind of love when Congress
talks about technology.
And this is the most important line.
"By blurring the line
between fact and fiction,
deepfake technology could
undermine public trust
in recorded images and video
as objective depictions of reality."
Oh, and by the way, this
letter was back in 2018.
Basically the Stone Age
for AI image generation.
More recently, I saw a Democratic senator
giving his opening remarks
to his colleagues in Congress
via a deepfaked voice that
sounded perfectly like him.
- [Man] We have seen what happens
when technology outpaces regulation.
- But it's not just American lawmakers.
(dark music)
Europol, which is the European
International Police Agency,
says that experts estimate that as much as
90% of online content may
be synthetically generated
by 2026.
90%.
Meaning AI will be
making most of the stuff
that we watch on the internet.
Their big fear in all of this
is that deepfakes will, quote,
"lead to a situation where citizens
no longer have a shared reality,"
causing what they call
(deep voice) an information apocalypse.
(normal voice) Here is a 43 page report
from the US Department
of Homeland Security,
and look at this title page!
I mean, look at that graphic design!
Especially this moment,
where it goes from a classic
sans serif, to a serif.
I mean, it's not bad for the government.
DHS says that deepfakes and
the misuse of synthetic content
pose a clear, present, and
evolving threat to the public,
across national security, law enforcement,
financial, and societal domains.
The Pentagon is using
its big research wing,
the one that helped invent, I don't know,
the GPS, the COVID vaccine,
and the literal internet.
That one.
To look into deepfakes,
and how to combat them.
Like, they're taking this very seriously.
But my big problem with
all of these reports is,
they're couched in such vague language!
What can deepfakes actually be used for,
outside of making really cool
Kendrick Lamar music videos
and TikTok Tom Cruises?
- I think there's bubble gum inside this.
(electronic whirring)
- Well, to get a taste, look
no further than Ukraine.
- The Russian president
says a military operation
is now underway in eastern Ukraine.
- [Woman] A column of Russian armor
crossing into Ukrainian
territory from the north.
(speaks foreign language)
- This is not Ukrainian
president Volodymyr Zelenskyy.
This is a deepfaked video
that appeared on a Russian
language Ukrainian news site
just four weeks after
Russia invaded Ukraine.
Russian troops were
trying to take over Kiev,
which would've meant a
massive victory for Putin.
Information on the ground
was scant and foggy,
and this video pops up,
of Volodymyr Zelenskyy urging his troops
to surrender to Russian forces.
Now listen, this is kind of a
crappy version of a deepfake.
I mean, misshapen head,
weird accent and voice.
Wasn't super pulled off.
But guess what?
It doesn't matter, because
what this video did do
is it made people
question every other video
coming out of Ukraine.
And this is what Congress meant
when they were freaking out in 2018
about the idea of
deepfakes blurring the line
between fact and fiction,
undermining trust in
recorded images and videos
as objective depictions of reality.
And this is actually, so
far in my reporting on this,
the biggest takeaway.
I don't know if we realize
what a big shift this is!
As deepfake technology gets better,
yes, it allows people to create
compelling fake evidence,
and that is worrisome.
But it also allows people
to dismiss real evidence,
real footage, as,
"Oh, that's just a deepfake.
We can do that now. We
can't trust anything."
- It's not just what they could create.
It's the doubt that is cast
on authentic video and audio.
- Yeah.
- Okay, let's get to another
concrete threat here,
to get us away from all the vague language
of government agencies talking
about how scary this all is.
Think about the legal system.
(electronic whirring)
Deepfakes are becoming a
nightmare for evidence in court.
In 2020, there was a child custody case,
where the mother presented as evidence
audio recording of the child's father
saying violent things over the phone.
It was submitted as legit evidence,
as proof to be like, "This
dad is unfit to have the kid."
But after some digital forensics,
it became clear that the mother
had used an online tutorial
and some cheap software
to doctor the audio file,
to add in fake violent words.
Most judges and juries
are not ready for this!
Most wouldn't think to
question evidence like this
that sounds like a smoking
gun, and yet was totally fake.
This sort of technology
is getting so accessible
and easy to use.
In fact, this VO that you're
listening to right now
is actually fake.
I made it using a cheap and easy software
widely available to anyone.
Now imagine that you're on a jury,
and you're presiding over a criminal case.
And even though there may not be
any manipulated evidence in front of you,
there's now a nagging voice
in the back of your mind, that's like,
"Remember that time that Johnny tricked me
in that YouTube video, and
he made his face change,
and now he looks like someone else,
and it wasn't really him,
and it was really convincing?
Who's to say all of this visual evidence
that I'm seeing in court isn't also fake?"
Visual evidence is no longer rock solid.
Surveillance footage, body cam footage,
heck, even audio taken in a bus
from a presidential candidate.
This was all solid at one point,
and now it can all be
called into question.
(electronic whirring)
And then of course,
deepfakes are being used for
good old fashioned cyber crime.
Man, cyber crime!
It just sounds so quaint.
Cyber crime.
Elon Musk was recently faked
to help shill a new crypto scam.
- (indistinct), a site that
will help ordinary people
to gain financial independence.
- And yeah, this one's
obviously fake and poorly done.
My point is they're getting better,
and some scams are already
way more persuasive.
Like this group of fraudsters
who were able to clone the
voice of a major bank director,
and then use it to steal $35
million in cold hard cash,
$35 million!
- [Man] That's a lot of money.
- Just by deepfaking this guy's voice,
and like, using it to make a phone call
to transfer a bunch of money.
And it worked!
Okay, but in reality,
the risk of eroding trust in the public
or weakening our legal system
or giving cyber criminals a new weapon,
all of these are actually
the rarest uses of deepfakes.
The main victims of this new technology,
at least at the moment, are women.
- [Man] These sexually suggestive
ads are popping up online.
- Sexual misuse of these deepfakes.
- She's been deepfaked.
- [Woman] That's not me.
- By one estimate, 96%
of deepfake production
is used to produce porn.
Almost all of which are using women
who have not consented to this.
Just two years ago,
Telegram got in trouble,
because it was found that they had
private groups on their service
that were using deepfake technology
to remove the clothes of more
than a hundred thousand women.
It used to just be the
faces of celebrities,
because they're the ones who have all this
high quality data out in the world
that you can train a model on.
But no longer.
The tech has developed such that
an ordinary person with a
few images on social media
could suddenly have their faces deepfaked
onto the body of a porn star.
- [Man] Martin has found dozens
of doctored images and videos of herself.
She has no idea who's
responsible for them.
- Okay, but what's being done about this?
What can be done?
Let's first remember that when
a new technology comes along,
it typically evolves rapidly,
way faster than the lawmakers
who need to understand
it to regulate it do.
So, we're in the kind of wild west phase,
where the lawmakers
are kind of just trying
to get their head around this stuff.
- Let's hope that Congress can catch up.
- China is actually the first
country to have regulated
what they call deep
synthesis technologies,
by requiring all deepfake content
to be clearly marked as
having been modified.
Luckily, a surveillance
state is a lot easier
to regulate this kind of stuff.
But the EU is trying.
- [Woman] In an ambitious
bill called the AI Act.
- Boy do I love going through
European Commission PowerPoint slides.
Like China, the EU is trying to make it
so that you have to label deepfakes.
But of course, in a Western democracy,
you have to put this line,
"unless necessary for the exercise
of a fundamental right or freedom,
or for reasons of public interest."
Oh man, those pesky rights
always getting in the way
of being able to regulate stuff.
The UK is also trying to figure this out.
They are targeting the porn situation,
the one that is the mass majority
of the uses of deepfakes.
Doing deepfake porn without consent
comes with a penalty of prison,
though it's super hard
to enforce this stuff.
That's what's so tricky.
But they're trying.
- Will the government take urgent action
and repair this mess?
- And then there's tech
companies, like here on YouTube.
They say that they will pull
down any video that, quote,
"Includes deceptive uses
of manipulated media,
ie. deepfakes, which may
pose serious risk of harm."
Who decides what serious risk of harm is?
Meh.
But one promising solution here
would be to fight software with software.
If we could train software
to detect the quirks of deepfakes,
like the unnatural blinking,
or some of the other weird subtle things
that the human eye can't pick up on,
we would have a strong way of verifying
what is real footage,
and what is distorted.
So deepfakes are here, and
they're seemingly here to stay.
We are entering a new chapter
of how humans consume and
relate to information.
It's a chapter as significant in my mind
as some of the other big chapters,
like when we learned to
capture light and record it.
It changed the world!
Photographs could be
used in court as proof.
They could be used in science to capture
and understand the world around us.
In journalism, it allowed
us to show, not just tell.
And when we made those images move,
we could capture more truth,
more proof, more evidence.
And then we could connect,
and spread those images far and wide.
Truth and evidence coursed
through the world's internet.
This evolution of the moving image
and its uses in the connected world
is taking an unexpected turn,
away from being the bedrock of evidence,
and towards the foggy territory
of deception and confusion.
We're gonna have to navigate
this chapter carefully.
We're gonna have to push even harder
to know where our images came from,
who made them, and for what purpose.
And we're gonna have to resist the urge
to believe everything we see,
no matter how real it looks.
(solemn music)